although hard presses are more common
this company makes the more traditional
soft big ones to make it up though for
4870 pretzels a worker first blend
shortening sugar and salt in a huge
mixer the machine automatically adds
yeast corn syrup 1638 gallons of cold
water and 760 pounds of flour the cold
water helps make the dough elastic so
workers can shape it before it hardens a
worker then opens the mixer and slows
the blades to help the dough fall out he
splits the match on a table then creates
chunks that go into a tank called a
hopper
it feeds an auger that channels the
dough chunks through little guillotines
the blades chop the chunks into two and
a half ounce balls to make small
pretzels or five ounce balls for large
pretzels two conveyor belts squeeze 15
and a half inch long segments called
noodles
another machine now grabs the ends of
each tool and twist the ends over each
other to create the pretzels three
signature holes another machine now
grabs the ends of each noodle and twist
the ends over each other to create the
pretzels three signature holes to keep
this knot from unraveling the plate then
gently flips the pretzel dough onto
another plate below that plate carefully
flips the dough creations onto a
118-foot long conveyer belt the raw
pretzels now travel on the conveyor for
14 minutes the time it takes for the
dough to rise next they move through
showers of liquid sodium hydroxide
heated to 180 degrees Fahrenheit that
seals in the moisture
so the pretzel will be chewy when you
eat it they go into an oven that's about
the length of a city bus
as they enter flame sear and harden the
outside this prevents the bottom from
sticking to the mesh conveyor belt
during baking after about three and a
half minutes at 560 degrees Fahrenheit
the pretzels are piping hot and
golden-brown they drop onto a long
conveyor where they gradually cool on
their way to the next step a trip
through a freezer that's longer than
seven Olympic sized swimming pools after
30 minutes at minus 18 degrees
Fahrenheit the pretzels are rock solid
and ready for packaging but first a
camera scans them so that a computer can
track each pretzel and guide a robotic
arm to pick it up this arm is one of
five that operates at separate points on
the line
the robots process one pretzel per
second and clean up after each other
until the Bell is picked clean the
pretzels then fall through a sliding
gate landing on a conveyor that whisks
them up to the next step there are
machine drops a packet of coarse salt
into each bin of six pretzels a
mechanical arm nudges the pretzels over
to make room for it the salt packet lets
you season your pretzel the traditional
way before warming it up at home the
machine blows open plastic bags with
compressed air mechanical arms push the
pretzels in salt packet inside a robot
arm then places each bag into a
cardboard box the printing on this
package displays the company logo the
nutritional content the production date
and the heating instructions so the next
time you're looking for a salty snack
don't tie yourself up in knots just have
a pretzel instead
you